joining us now utah senator mike lee
author of the new book saving nine and
former law clerk to justice
alito
um senator it turns out that
this vitriol during the kavanaugh
hearings was just the beginning wasn't
it
just the beginning seems to be getting
worse they know only contempt for the
rule of law and now contempt for the
justices themselves that's tragic
well how dangerous could this get
senator i mean
sending people to the homes of the
justices i mean you do that when
someone's nominated to the court and
it's kind of dramatic remember you take
your coffee on the way until they show
the video but this is something quite
different
the marshall's office i understand is
quite worried about this
they are quite worried and they have
every reason to be quite worried look
in this day and age and in particular
laura there is never a good legitimate
reason to go and protest at the home of
a public official this is a place
where they sleep this is a place where
if they've got children in home or
they're raising children it's an
implicit threat of physical violence and
that has no place in our system of
government certainly no place in our
judicial system and yet that's what
they're wanting to do and remember laura
why they're doing this they're doing
this to delegitimize
degrade and isolate those members of the
supreme court who may be considering
joining the masterfully written and
eminently correct opinion of justice
alito in the dobbs case this is simply
unacceptable look they made a
constitutional doctrine out of whole
cloth one that doesn't exist
they're mad now because the supreme
court is finally recognizing that it
doesn't exist and they're wanting to use
violence to get their way that's
shameful
and senator lee the gop establishment
you know
i've not been big friends with them on a
lot of issues
and on these social issues they mouth
the platitudes of being pro-life but
then when it came to this decision you
see kind of a lot of them like go well
let's move on talk about taxes or
inflation
you have been such a stalwart pro-life
um senator and advocate for your whole
really your whole life you're being
challenged by a so-called independent
being funded by out-of-state
billionaires and other leftist activists
uh so i was getting all these texts and
knew you were coming in coming in they
said how do we help mike lee how do we
help mike lee uh
i don't know how we help you because i
think you're you know you're obviously
gonna win this but
tell me what's going on here in this
race
well first of all anyone who wants to
help me can do so by going to my website
at leadforsenate.com that's
leaforsenate.com and when they go to
leave for senate.com what they will
discover is that i'm being challenged by
an opponent
one who's running as an independent but
has now been backed by the democratic
party one who voted for joe biden
encouraged others to vote for joe biden
and has praised joe biden while
criticizing everything donald trump ever
did
this is not someone who has the
interests of the american people or the
constitution at heart
and the economy and all the other issues
we've been talking about crime and so
forth they're willing to throw all those
away uh in order to try to kill off the
america first agenda mitt romney um
the fact that he's not endorsed you is
shameful people of utah deserve uh you
to get reelected and i'm looking forward
to watching this race senator lee thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else